a 42 here in 1902 an archaeologist was
diving off the coast of the Greek island
of Antikythera when he chanced upon a
large shipwreck it was the ruins of a
Roman trading vessel carrying large
amounts of wine and various other
treasures from the Greek islands what
the diver found was one of the greatest
halls of antiquity period artifacts we
have ever found but among the pottery
marble statues and jewelry inside an
unassuming wooden box was an object that
historians have never ever seen before a
device so bewildering that it altered
everything we knew about ancient history
this highly corroded bronze relic is the
Antikythera mechanism named after where
it was found but beyond that it is
shrouded in mystery what we do know is
that it was constructed by an unknown
Greek scientist over 2100 years ago the
strange mechanical device is made up of
numerous gears switches and mechanical
oddities upon its discovery scientists
pulled their hair up
trying to deduce where it came from who
made it how does it work and what does
it do scientists from all over the world
examined the device for over a hundred
years but nobody ever got remotely close
to uncovering its secrets and so for the
past 100 years
the Antikythera mechanism has sat on
display at the National Museum of
Archaeology in Athens Greece completely
undisturbed shrouded in mystery until
recently over the past 20 years using a
whole array of modern technologies we
have been able to crack the code behind
this unknown mechanism a whole host of
experts in the fields of engineering
archaeology and various other Sciences
from multiple countries collaborated in
an effort to painstakingly pick apart
the device
but there was a problem being such a
significant historic relic the
Antikythera mechanism couldn't literally
be picked apart so to see beneath the
surface scientists had to use a highly
specialized x-ray machine which
presented another problem one of the
only x-ray machines in the world capable
of seeing inside this corroded bronze
Marvel was located in England the relic
itself is far too fragile to be moved
outside of its Athens museum so the
extremely large and heavy x-ray machine
had to be shipped all away to Athens
that's a great expense so that the relic
could be safely imaged without moving it
more than a few metres but the details
that they uncovered inside the device
blew the minds of every antiquity
historian out there because the
technology used inside it shouldn't have
existed over 2,000 years ago when it was
made the complex clock-like device
contains 37 gears of varying sizes
shapes and teeth counts each cog is
precisely manufactured to exacting
standards and has a teeth count that
correlates to a prime number what you're
looking at ladies and gentlemen is the
world's very first computer over 2,000
years before the Apple one and over two
thousand years before Alan Turing's
bomba it's incredible to think that this
is an actual computer that can take an
input and compute an output that was
invented and created in roughly 100 b.c
over one and a half thousand years
before arguably less complex things like
the printing press the light bulb and
the steam engine whirring vent
so what does the Antikythera mechanism
do before I tell you I'd like to take a
minute to thank Skilsaw for supporting
me and making this video possible
Skillshare is an online learning
community with more than 17,000 classes
and design photo illustration almost
anything you've always wanted to learn
you can do so with Skillshare
all the way from game design to how to
cook like a professional chef anyone
who's watched my channel for a while
will know that I love to cook in my
spare time and you can bet I've been
learning some incredible new cooking
skills on Skillshare Premium Membership
gives you unlimited access to over
17,000 classes so you can keep on
learning and take on a new project
whenever you feel like it the first 500
people to click the promo link in a
description below will get two months of
Skillshare premium completely free after
that it's only ten dollars per month if
you don't like it cancel there's no risk
but for my own experience I just know
you're going to love it you can even
learn as you go with the new skill share
mobile apps even when you're offline but
remember only the first 500 people to
click the link below will get to mums
completely free using the most advanced
technology available tools today and the
collective work of many experts over a
number of years we have been able to
determine that this ancient computers
function was to track the metonic
calendar and predict solar eclipses it
also keeps track of the timing of
several athletic games such as the
ancient Olympics this device should not
exist it is so incomprehensibly ahead of
its time that it's almost impossible to
believe that it was created when it was
to put things into perspective the first
mechanical clock wasn't invented until
late 14th century and it was roughly the
size of a small car yet this device
created 1,500 years earlier in ancient
Greece was considerably smaller
more intricate more precisely engineered
and many times smarter for it could not
only keep track of time but predict the
future in the way that's a piece of
modern computer software the Antikythera
mechanism contains sets of gears pins
and rivets that could collectively model
and keep track of the movement of the
Sun Moon and planets in the night sky
this is a diagram of the logic pathways
of the Antikythera mechanism showing the
functions of each gear if such a device
were created today it would still be
impressive it is believed that the
knowledge used to create such an
advanced device was lost in antiquity as
nothing anywhere close to as
sophisticated as this would be created
for another thousand years the gross in
probability of its existence has of
course led to many science fiction
writers claiming it was created by or
given tools by aliens but the
Antikythera mechanism isn't the first
out-of-place historic artifact which has
been blamed on aliens in 1912 a Polish
book dealer named Wilfred Voynich
travelled to Villa Mondragon II in Italy
where he discovered and purchased a very
old and very mysterious book it had no
title upon the cover and no author
within it it contained hundreds of pages
of detailed yet bizarre illustrations
surrounded by text that is written in an
unknown language or possibly a code for
the remainder of his life avoiding it
became completely obsessed with decoding
the books words and diagrams to try and
understand who wrote it when and where
was it written and what does it all mean
having dedicated his entire life to
unlocking the book secrets Voynich died
having come no closer to answering any
of these questions the book has been
given the name the Voynich manuscript
script after the man who found it and so
the Voynich manuscript was passed around
from one cryptographer to another both
American and British codebreakers
attempted to decode it during World War
one and - with absolutely no success it
has come to be one of the most famous
unsolved codes in the entire history of
cryptography even using the most
sophisticated computer Crypt analyst
techniques available to us today we have
still not even come close to solving it
linguists have examined the manuscript
and concluded that its contents are not
written in any natural historic language
that we know of this only leaves two
likely alternatives the book is written
in a very old language that we are
completely unaware of that was lost to
time or the other option it is written
using a cipher a secret code to disguise
the true contents of the text this means
that whatever is written in the Voynich
manuscript is of such high importance
and significance that the author felt it
necessary to painstakingly encode every
word the animal skin parchments that the
manuscript is written on was recently
carbon dated the results showed that the
book was written sometime between 1404
and 1438 cryptography was really very
basic at this time in history the only
effective method of cryptography that
had been discovered in the 15th century
were substitution ciphers in which each
letter of the alphabet is simply swapped
with another using modern computers we
have long been able to crack such
ciphers with ease in fact we have been
able to crack every known cipher up to
the 18th century long after the Voynich
manuscript was supposedly written
yes this one mysterious book still
remains uncrackable the illustrations
consist of a variety of herbal plants as
well as nude women bathing astrological
symbols and visual metaphors some of the
illustrations contained within have an
uncanny resemblance to images from the
natural world that would not have even
been seen by humans for another few
hundred years after the manuscripts
inception such as this illustration that
looks remarkably similar to a galaxy and
this which has a resemblance of a plant
cell yet the telescope and microscope
wouldn't be invented until 200 years
later there are many aspects to this
manuscript that are historically out of
place and way ahead of their time
leading many to believe that the Voynich
manuscript is the memoirs of an alien
who was stranded on planet Earth which
could also explain the alien like
language yes I know it seemed like
whenever the Internet is struggling to
explain something it turns to aliens
other theories from various scholars
around the world include the Voynich
manuscript was written by medieval
scientist Roger Bacon or even by a young
Leonardo da Vinci but the carbon dating
of the book puts its inception out of
both of these men's lifetimes it has
been fought by many that's if we could
crack the Voynich manuscript we would
unlock the secret to eternal youth as
many of the illustrations seem to allude
to this over say it's in alchemists
handbook and it contains hundreds of
powerful alchemy recipes long lost
but one incredible aspect of the Voynich
manuscript which I can't wrap my head
around is that upon examination under a
microscope there is not a single mistake
or error across all 260 plus pages of
this mysterious codex there is not one
piece of evidence that suggests that a
correction was made by the author
considering that it contains many
thousands of words written in a secret
code and some of the most complex
detailed and beautiful illustrations
from a book of this time period
including a masterfully illustrated six
page foldouts the fact that not a single
mistake was made by the author is quite
frankly unbelievable superhuman in fact
today it sits securely in the Beinecke
Rare Book and Manuscript library at yet
it is undoubtedly the most mysterious
book within the library's vast
collection every few years another
learning scholar tries to look at
deciphering the book stacks and
unlocking its secrets or have so far
failed thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon to help me
make more videos click here to watch
another video and if you haven't already
don't forget to subscribe also be quick
and click the link below if you want to
get two months of Skillshare completely
free